Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit mal wieder in Spaniens Liga zu gucken und das wollen wir machen mit niemanden geringerem als Nils Kern von realtotal.de. Aber es wird nicht nur über Real gehen. Nils, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt im Rasenfunk. Hi.
Hola, qué tal, Max? Mein erstes Mal. Ich freue mich.
Ja, sehr schön. Das ist die richtige Energie. Da wollen wir auch gleich mal ignorieren, dass ich hier mit grammatikalisch höchstfragwürdigen Formulierungen eingestiegen bin. Erzähl uns doch mal. Du bist Chefredakteur bei real total auf Twitter. At real unterstrich total. Wer hätte es gedacht? Was macht ihr denn da?
Was machen wir da? Wir schreiben natürlich über Real Madrid. Hauptsächlich wir sind ein Fachmagazin über die Königlichen, also wirklich spezialisiert auf den spanischen Rekordmeister. Und das machen wir schon seit über zehn Jahren eigentlich, als die Seite so nach und nach entstanden ist. Mittlerweile bin ich seit so drei, vier Jahren der Chefredakteur da, lebe auch in Madrid selbst, sprich bin bei Pressekonferenzen, Heimspielen meistens dabei. Und wenn dann mal was los ist, Toni Kroos in der Mixon-Interview. Also da sind wir so als einziges deutsches Medium immer vor Ort dabei, haben guten Draht zum Verein. Aber wenn auch sonst was in der Liga ist, bericht mal darüber auch. Und dann habe ich sogar noch einen Podcast, Tiki Taka, gemeinsam mit Alex Troika von Barca-Welt, also es gibt viel zu tun im spanischen Fußball, speziell natürlich bei den Königlichen.
Genau, der Tiki Taka Podcast, unbedingt empfehlenswert für all diejenigen, die sagen, wie kann das sein, dass der Rasenfunk jetzt monatelang nicht über La Liga gesprochen hat? Da wird euch geholfen, da treffen euch die beiden Großmächte, eben barcawelt.de und Real total treffender aufeinander. Und ich vermute, es geht in jeder Folge blutig zu. Nichts, alles andere würde mich enttäuschen, Nils.
Blutig auch heute Morgen erst wieder aufgenommen. Ich muss hier gerade noch mit dem Arm bandagiert aufnehmen. Aber es ist selten langweilig, immer lustig, mit dem Alex zu diskutieren, wann keine Faul war und warum der Schiri...
Na ja, den Alex hatten wir ja auch schon mit dabei. Es wurde höchste Zeit, dass du jetzt mal nachziehst. Wer dir folgen möchte, kann das tun, als etnilskern17 auf Twitter. Aber jetzt genug der Vorrede. Du hast die Ehre, über Real zu sprechen. Und wir können auch mit Real anfangen, denn wir wollen mal die Tabelle von oben nach unten so ein bisschen durchgehen und bei den bemerkenswerten Teams hängen bleiben. Da müssen wir über Madrid sprechen. Und da sehe ich, dass sich gar nicht so viel getan hat zur letzten Folge, die ja schon wirklich eine ganze Weile zurückliegt. Weiter steht Real nur bei einer Niederlage, hat nur 14 Gegentore nach 23 Spielen und damit drei Punkte Vorsprung aktuell auf Barca. Wie läuft's denn so? Sieht ja ganz gut aus von den Zahlen her.
Die Zahlen können sich tatsächlich sehen lassen. Sie haben jetzt im Pokal das erste Mal eine Niederlage seit wettbewerbsübergreifend 21 Spielen kassiert. Also Zidane hat es irgendwie geschafft, die Mannschaft wieder so aufzustellen, dass sie wieder wettbewerbsfähig ist. Du erinnerst dich ja 2018, 2019 war nicht ganz so eine historische Saison bei den Königlichen mit drei Trainern und die ersten Saison nach Cristiano Ronaldo. Aber diese Saison sieht das tatsächlich schon wieder besser aus, weil, das liegt nicht unbedingt an einem Ronaldo-Ersatz, sondern weil die Defensive plötzlich steht. 14 Gegentore in La Liga, das ist der beste Wert in Europas Top-Ligen. Also irgendwie hat sie da noch mal den Griff gefunden, um Ramos und Co. wieder so motivieren zu können, dass sie stehen. Und auch Thibaut Couture hat mittlerweile Selbstvertrauen. Es läuft wieder, hat so viele weiße Westen, wie schon lange nicht mehr, wurde jetzt auch heute erst frisch zum Spieler des Monats Januar in La Liga ausgezeichnet. Also da gibt es viele Sachen, die gut laufen. Toni Kroos scheint wieder über sich hinaus zu wachsen, nachdem er auch ein eher schwächeres 18, 19 hatte. Karim Benzema ist wieder ein alter Top-Form. Danika Wachal sowieso immer, Varan sowieso immer. Also Sidane hat irgendwie wieder den Draht gefunden.
Sidane war mir jetzt nicht als Defensiv-Experte bekannt. Kannst du denn ein bisschen beschreiben, wie schafft es denn Real Madrid, so wenige Tore zu kassieren? Bespielt man einen besonders stabilen Fußball, der vor allem zuerst auf die Defensive schaut und dann auf die Offensive? Wie macht er das? Er parkt ja wahrscheinlich nicht den Bus, weil irgendwie muss man auch Tore erzielen.
Der Bus wird nicht geparkt. Nur, es ist nicht mehr ganz so der Fokus auf voll nach vorne rennen und dann auch möglichst Risiken eingehen und vielleicht nur noch einen Varan hinten stehen zu lassen, der damit sonst keiner mehr absichert. Das ist einfach wieder eine Mischung auch aus Motivation, dass ein Varan und Ramos keine Risiken eingehen und auch sicher die Zweikämpfe führen, da gar nicht groß vorm Strafraum rumfauen oder auch im Strafraum. Da ist einfach Real Madrid viel sicherer aufgestellt. Am System hat sich gar nicht viel geändert. Es hieß zwar in der Sommerpause, auch durch den Transfer von Luka Jovic, dass man vielleicht mit einer Art Doppelspitze spielen könnte, 4-4-2, aber eigentlich ist es bei dem 4-3-3 geblieben, was Real Madrid seit Jahren aufs Parkett legt. Da wird natürlich ab und zu mal variiert, wenn man gegen einen flügellastigen Gegner wie Sevilla spielt. Aber eigentlich ist es immer noch dieses 4-3-3, wie man es schon immer kennt. Und so gesehen hat sie dann auch eine kleine Schwachstelle vielleicht erkannt in der Viererkette. Das war dann doch oft Marcello in den letzten Jahren, der jetzt auch ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen ist, sage ich mal. Dem wurde jetzt mehr und mehr durch Neuzugang Ferland Mendy. Der kam aus Lyon, der Rang abgelaufen. Also er sorgt schon mal für eine defensive, wichtige Komponente, weswegen die Gegner durch die Reals linke Seite nicht mehr so oft durchbrechen. Auch Ramos hat sich wieder ein bisschen gefangen. Ist zwar jetzt auch schon ein bisschen alt mit seinen 33 Jahren, aber wie gesagt, hat sich nochmal gefangen, war an nach wie vor Weltklasse auch Cavajal wieder zu alter Topform gefunden. Und jetzt mehr oder weniger auch konkurrenzlos hat er auch eigentlich Otto de Ussola, der zum FC Bayern gegangen ist, kaum eine Chance gelassen, da mal zu spielen, weil er selbst einfach wieder in Form ist. Und so kommt das dann zu zusammen, auch weil dazu noch kommt, dass ein Casemere wohl der vielleicht beste Saison, beste Matrilene in dieser Saison ist, was zumindest unsere Noten bei Real total angeht und auch sonst schon allerlei Auszeichnung von La Liga bekommen hat. Und einfach, was überlebenswichtig ist, vorne wie hinten, Bälle er riecht, erspäht und auch jede Menge Zweikämpfe gewinnt.
Genau, das Mittelfeld sieht nämlich genauso aus, wie man es eigentlich immer schon kannte. Casemiro, Modric und Kroos ist da die Dreierreihe. Hat sich denn offensiv an der Art und Weise, wie Real spielt, etwas getan?
Das ist aktuell natürlich nicht ganz so, wie es vielleicht Sidan geplant hatte, weil Eden Hazard ist jetzt seit Ende November verletzungsbedingt außen vor. Er hat einen Mikko-Riss gegen Paris erlitten, wird jetzt aber vielleicht am kommenden Wochenende schon seinen Comeback geben nach zweieinhalb Wochen. Da war schon mehr, dass man einen Faktor hatte, der in der letzten Saison, in dieser Krisensaison gefiltert hat, der einfach auch mal drei Gegenspieler stehen lässt, mal nichts aus dem Stand irgendwie was schafft und ein bisschen unberechenbarer auf dem Spiel agiert. So sind die Königlichen aktuell immer noch eine Mannschaft, die die zweitmeisten Flanken pro Spiel in der Liga abgibt, 22 Stück, nur der FC Sevilla gibt mehr ab. Also das ist schon oft, ich will nicht sagen, ideenlos, aber eben immer noch ein bisschen das gleiche Prinzip. Trotzdem reicht es aktuell noch, weil eben Benzema vorne knipst und auch irgendwie die Mannschaft sich auch nach Rückschlägen wieder, wie gesagt, man zusammenreißt, wie es jetzt auch am Wochenende bei Ustas Sunava, da lag man früh 0-1 zurück, hat auch ziemlich gewackelt in der Defensive, aber trotzdem kommt wieder so ein bisschen dieses königliche Siegergehen. Hervor, Isco hat den Ausgleich beschert und dann natürlich Sergio Ramos war auch zur Stelle mal wieder in dem Tor. Also diese Einstellung, dieser Siegeswille ist wieder neu in Fach durch Zidane und das eben mit alten Systemen und Benzema ist eigentlich trotzdem irgendwie so vielleicht einer der wenigen, die nach Ronaldos Abgang einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben, wohl gegen Gareth Belli oder Marco Asensio, die haben das nicht getan. Benzema hat dadurch jetzt auch aktuell Ronaldo abgelöst als der Rekordvorlagengeber der Königlichen. Benzema steht jetzt bei 132 Assists seit 2009. Ronaldo schafft es da seit 2009 auf 131 Assists. Also auch da schon mal Benzema so den nächsten Schritt gemacht oder Ronaldo den Rang abgelaufen oder wie auch immer. Man sagt, das Denkmal ein eigenes Daneben gesetzt.
Und welche Rolle spielt dann Luka Jovic?
Luka Jovic hat aktuell noch sehr viel Pech. Er kam ja mit einer großen Ansage von 60 Millionen Euro nach Madrid, weil Zidane ihn auch unbedingt haben wollte. Er hat, wie wir alle, diese unglaublichen Tore für Frankfurt gesehen in der Bundesliga und der Europa League. Aktuell steht Luka Jovic noch bei erst zwei Treffern, hat aber trotzdem schon einiges an Einsatzzeit jetzt auch. 764 Minuten. Das war am Anfang der Saison noch ein bisschen weniger, dann war Benzema mal kurz verletzt. Also er kommt schon auch zu seinen Startelf-Gelegenheiten, aber konnte das bislang noch nicht so zurückzahlen, wie er das auch selbst erwartet hat. Er hat jetzt in einem Interview erst gesagt, er schaut sich die Videos von der letzten Saison an und fragt sich selbst, was ist da los. Glücklicherweise jetzt am Wochenende hat er mal wieder so ein typisches Jovic-Tor gemacht. Technisch anspruchsvoll, aus 16 Metern, Direktabnahme mit dem schwachen Fuß in den Winkel, das konnte sich sehen lassen. Die Fans in Madrid, mit denen ich so rede, die wissen schon auch, dass er eigentlich ein absoluter Killer ist. Nur, man braucht halt doch auch ein bisschen Geduld und Zeit in Madrid. Benzema hat damals lange Zeit benötigt und jetzt Luka Jovic ist auch im Spiel noch nicht so integriert, wie das vielleicht sein müsste. Jetzt habe ich ja gesagt, Madrid ist eine sehr flankenaffine Mannschaft, aber trotzdem kam da noch nicht so viel an, wie das vielleicht sein müsste, er muss ja gefüttert werden. Er hat auch schon oft Pech gehabt, was waren das, 3 Aluminium-Treffer, 2 abseits-bedingt aber erkannte Tore schon dabei, also diese Torbilanz von ihm könnte auch schon ganz anders lauten als nur 2 im Anführungszeichen mickrige Treffer, aber Zidane und Peres, der Präsident, schenken ihm das absolute Vertrauen und das wird schon noch besser werden mit ihm, nur vielleicht ist ja jetzt am Wochenende der Knotenmalge platzt bei Luka Jovic.
Und dann haben wir ja vorne drin noch zwei Brasilianer, die ich ganz interessant finde. Zum einen Vinicius Junior, den man im letzten Jahr, vor allem im letzten Jahr, kam der mit so einem Big Bang, hatte ich den Eindruck, auf die europäische Fußballbühne und da sah es auch kurz so aus, huch, könnten die eventuell da direkt einen Ronaldo-Nachfolger gefunden haben und mit Rodrigo ja noch jemanden, der jetzt zu dieser Saison gekommen ist, der auch eben beide 19 Jahre alt oder 19 Jahre jung, muss man ja sagen, und beide hoch veranlagt. Was kannst du mir denn zu den beiden erzählen? Ist der Hype, den ich jetzt gerade starten will, gerechtfertigt?
Gerechtfertigt wird sich natürlich noch zeigen. Vinicius war so in der letzten Saison einer der einzigen leuchtenden Punkte im königlichen Spiel, wurde auch lange nicht berücksichtigt, erst dann so nach der Winterpause sich wirklich hochgespielt und eben auch mal was auf dem Platz gezeigt, wofür die Zuschauer vor allem im Benabio Eintritt zahlen und auch was sie sehen wollen. Mal ein paar Tricks, mal ein paar unberechenbare Szenenbewegungen, das hat Vinicius damals absolut gezeigt in der vergangenen Saison. Jetzt aktuell scheint ihm Rodrigo mehr oder weniger ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen zu haben. Zumindest ist Rodrigo in seiner Debüt-Saison hinter Benz im Aas 18 Toren mit 7 Treffern der zweitbeste Torjäger der königlichen. Er hat aktuell auch ein kleines Formtief, dafür ist Vinicius gerade wieder in die Formkurve ein bisschen nach oben. Mal spielt er, mal spielt der andere. Sie dann rotiert auch immer mal wieder. Trotzdem sind beide natürlich starke Talente. Vinicius ist noch ein bisschen im Tripling und in der Vorarbeit. Rodrigo dafür ein bisschen mehr im Abschluss. Da hat Vinicius schon einige Chancen liegen lassen. Trotzdem ist man da auch sehr geduldig mit den beiden. Das ist natürlich in Madrid auch immer schwierig mit dem Druck. Dann wird auch schnell mal Fans kritisieren, viele auf Social Media. Wenn da so ein Marker-Cover kommt mit Flop Vinicius oder so, ist das auch nicht gerade unterstützend. Da hat Vinicius auch schon oft emotionale Torjubel gezeigt, so halb mit Tränen schon nach einem Treffer. Es sind große Talente. Ich sag mal noch nicht, dass da jetzt direkt die nächsten Mbappé, Sancho und Co-Karriere kommen. Im Endeffekt hat Real Madrid für beide jeweils 45 Millionen Euro hingelegt. Das ist auch so ein bisschen die Strategie der königlichen, nicht mehr fertige Weltstars zu kaufen, wie das vielleicht noch nach der Jahrtausendwende möglich war mit Zidane, Figo, Beckham, Ronaldo und so weiter. Weil eben jetzt auch viel mehr Potenzial im Markt steckt oder viel mehr Mitbieter. Es gibt City, Paris, die können genauso ein hohes Gehalt bieten. Deswegen ist Madrid da seit Jahren, holt sich junge Spieler. Ascencio kam sehr jung, ein Varan kam sehr jung, Casemiro kam als No-Name, aktuell ist da auch so ein Name wie Federico Valverde hervorzuheben mit seinen 21 Jahren. Der kam für auch nur 5 Millionen, glaube ich, ist aktuell Stammspieler. Also Madrid fährt da mit dieser Strategie schon ganz richtig. Ab und zu klappt das nicht. Mal ist das ein Lucas Silva oder ein Asi Iyarra Mendy, Thierry Hernandez, der jetzt bei Milan aufblüht, wo es eben nicht so klappt. Aber Vinicius Rodrigo sind auf einem guten Weg, haben aber natürlich noch einen Weiten vor sich.
Und mit Manchester City als Mitbietenden und mit Paris als Mitbietenden um die Welt, das hast du ja auch schon zwei Champions-League-Gegner von Real Madrid angesprochen. Die einen hatte man in der Gruppe, da gab es einen 0 zu 3 in Paris und dann ein 2 zu 2 zu Hause. Und die anderen sind jetzt der Gegner im Champions-League-Achtelfinale. Mich hat dieses Copa del Rey aus im Viertelfinale gegen Real. Ich habe gewundert, wie das entsteht, 4 Tore zu kassieren und mit 3 zu 4 rauszugehen. Das ist jetzt nicht so typisch für Real Madrid. Wie würdest du denn jetzt deren Situation international einordnen? Copa del Rey ist nicht der wichtigste Pokal. Der wichtigste Pokal ist die Champions League. Da wartet jetzt aber mit Manchester City die eine Mannschaft, die, wenn sie noch irgendwas reisen will, dann in der Champions League etwas reißen muss.
Ja, da sprichst du was Gutes an, vor allem auch noch mal kurz zum Pokal aus. Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, Zidane kann die Jungs wieder motivieren und sie sind wieder voll im Saft und haben Lust, Titel zu gewinnen. Das hat man in der Copa in dem Spiel nicht gesehen. Da hat Zidane vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu viel rotiert und auch der, wie gesagt, wichtigste in der Saison, Casemiro, hat sogar angeschlagen, mit Grippe gefehlt. Also da kam einiges zusammen, sie kamen noch fast zurück. Real Sociedad hat ja 3-0 geführt und am Ende war es dann noch ein 4-3. Lief einiges blöd, aber eigentlich ist das... Na gut, dann sind wir halt wieder in der Kuppa ausgeschieden. Die gab es jetzt in diesem Jahrtausend eh erst zweimal. Dafür gibt es eben wirklich den Fokus auf die beiden wichtigeren Titel auf die Liga. Da haben die Königlichen auch jetzt keine so positive Bilanz in diesem Jahrtausend. Da hat Barca einige Titel zuletzt gewonnen und natürlich die Fans gieren immer nach der Königsklasse. Also Kuppa ist schade, aber alles andere als ein Hals- und Beinbruch. Und jetzt Champions League gegen City. Das ist natürlich das attraktivste Duell auch in diesem Achtelfinale, sag ich mal, weil es die einzige Paarung ist, wo wirklich zwei Titelkandidaten aufeinandertreffen. Bisher haben die Königlichen mehr oder weniger positive Erfahrungen mit City gemacht. Da ist man sich mal im Halbfinale begegnet in Sidans erster Saison, als es dann direkt zum ersten Champions League-Titel reichte. Also so ein bisschen positive Gefühle. Trotzdem natürlich wird das ein spannender, enger Kampf. Aber man hat Madrid jetzt wieder die Hoffnung, dass Eden Hazard zurückkommt, mit dem man jetzt auch schon die letzten acht Ligaspiele alle gewonnen hat. Also es läuft schon auch ohne Hazard, auch ohne diesen unberechenbaren Faktor auf der Außensbahn. Trotzdem läuft es. Und ja, City ist natürlich genauso motiviert bei so einem Rückstand auf Liverpool. Also es wird dann auch voll und auch endlich mal wieder laut im Benabio. Die Fans haben auch extrem Lust auf dieses Spiel. Da hat man auch 18, 19 gesehen, dass das Stadion kaum noch gefüllt war, weil alle satt waren und genug gesehen haben in den Jahren davor. Und jetzt dieses Jahr ist es wieder so weit, da kann Real wieder angreifen.
Gut, das werden wir mit Interesse verfolgen, was da in der Champions League passieren wird. Dann lassen wir über Barca sprechen, bei allem, was wir über Real Madrid gerade gesagt haben. Und bei allem, was bei Barca zu sehen ist, nämlich schon vier Niederlagen und vier Unentschieden, sind es trotzdem nur drei Pünktchen Rückstand auf Real. Wie schätzt du da die Situation ein?
Da gab es ja jetzt im Januar den großen Trainerwechsel beim FC Barcelona. Also Ernesto Valverde musste als Tabellenführer gehen. Dann kam Kikesettien und plötzlich sind die königlichen Tabellenführer. Das hat sich schon von der vorm Kurve her mehr oder weniger angebahnt. Im Endeffekt war es dann eine 0-2-Pleite von Barca in Valencia, wo man absolut mal verlieren kann, die den Tabellenwechsel an der Tabellenspitze herbeigeführt hat. Unter Kikesettien läuft es eigentlich ganz okay. Es gab jetzt schon fünf Siege in sieben Spielen. Er versucht wieder ein bisschen mehr auf dieses alte Barca-Tugenden a la Johan Cruyff hinzugehen. Es gab da schon Spiele mit über 1000 Pässen, mit denen man sich dann ganz stolz gewappnet hat. Nur ist das noch nicht wirklich in offensiver Gefahr umgemünzt. Das war aktuell noch nicht zu sehen. Am Ende bei Betis auch ein schwieriges Feld. 3-2 gewonnen nach zwei Mal Rückständen. Da auch ein Zeichen von der Mannschaft her gezeigt, von wegen sie sind wieder eine Einheit und kämpfen wieder. Alles meckern auf hohem Niveau. Sie sind ja durch die Champions League auch durchmarschiert und immer noch drei Punkte hinter dem Tabellenführer. Aber da gibt es schon einige Baustellen, auch durch Verletzungen. Luis Suarez fällt jetzt noch zwei, drei Monate verletzt aus. Usman Dembélé muss jetzt operiert werden, wird wohl auch in dieser Saison nicht mehr auf dem Platz stehen. Deswegen könnte es sogar sein, dass Barca ausnahmsweise noch einen Stürmer verpflichten darf, weil sie aktuell nur noch Grießmann Messi und den, wie heißt er, 18-Jährigen oder 17, Anzou Fati, von Hart 17, also ziemlich dünn vorne besetzt. Da gab es dann eben jetzt auch das Pokal aus, wie die königlichen Barca unglücklich in Bilbao ausgeschieden. Man setzt so ein bisschen auf die alten Tugenden. Viel Ballbesitz, viele Pässe, wenig Flanken, wenig lange Bälle, so ziemlich das Gegenteil zu den königlichen. Aber da ist es auch das Gegenteil zu Real Madrid. Man hat hier eine sehr schwache Defensive. Also Piquet merkt man das Alter deutlich an, hat jetzt auch schon 10 gelbe Karten mit seinen 33 Jahren. Allein aus dem Kopper aus gibt es eine berühmte Szene von ihm, wie er einfach Iñaki Williams nur noch stoppen konnte, indem er sich sekundenlang an sein Trikot gehangen hat. Die Jungs wackeln oft hinten drin. Longley ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt absolute Weltklasse. Und dadurch dann 28 Gegentorch an 23 Spieltagen. Das ist viel zu viel für Barca Ansprüche. Trotzdem, dadurch, dass sowohl Real als Atletico regelmäßig mal oder mal für den Unentschieden oder Pazer gut sind, sieht es in der Tabelle noch ein bisschen eng aus. Und Barca und Real sind noch nicht komplett davongezogen, wie das vielleicht in den letzten Jahren der Fall war.
Ja, aber bei einer Sache bin ich hellhörig geworden. Was meinst du mit, sie dürfen jetzt vielleicht noch einen Stürmer nachverpflichten? Also ist das Transferfenster schon zu in La Liga, so wie hier in der Bundesliga?
Ja, das ist schon zu. Aber in La Liga gibt es eine Sonder-Ausnahmeregelung. Wenn ein Spieler fünf Monate ausfällt, dann darf ein Verein einen Ersatz holen, allerdings nur innerhalb von La Liga oder einem vertraglosen Spieler. Und der darf dann auch nur für die nationalen Wettbewerbe angemeldet werden. Sprich, sollte Barca jetzt bei Levante, Osasuna wo auch wo will, dann dürfte dieser Stürmer nicht in der Champions League spielen. Dazu auch eine mehr oder weniger interessante Sache. In Spanien, die Arbeitsverträge haben alle eine Ausstiegsklausel. Also ist das, könnte man nicht mal sagen, welcher Verein ist schon so blöden, gibt jetzt seinen Top-Torjäger her. Da werden aktuell einige Namen gehandelt, wie der Loren Moron von Betis oder ich glaube auch William José von Real Sociedad wurde gehandelt. Also eigentlich alle Spieler, die gerade mindestens so um die 10 Tore knapp darunter liegen, könnten da gerade gehandelt werden. Und wenn die irgendwie eine 50, eine 60 Millionen als Ausstiegsklausel in ihrem Vertrag haben, dann könnte Barca dazuschlagen, sofern man sich natürlich mit dem Spieler einigt.
Und darf dann Suarez auch für diese fünf Monate nicht spielen?
Suarez ist da jetzt nicht betroffen von der Regel. Der fällt jetzt nur drei, vier Monate aus. Ist jetzt auch schon ein Monat weg. Aber Dembélé ist es jetzt. Der war jetzt auch schon zwei Monate außen vor und jetzt wird er operiert. Da gibt es auch jeden Tag noch mal eine neue Wasserstandsmeldung. Und es gibt jetzt auch keine offizielle Bestätigung, dass Barcelona Gebrauch von dieser Regel nehmen wird. Es ist nur einfach wahrscheinlich. Und deswegen ein bisschen Geschmäckle von Wettbewerbsverzerrung. So diese Regel fand zuletzt Anwendung. Ich glaube, das war vor zwei Jahren. Da hat Real Sociedad plötzlich seinen Torhüter verloren und durfte dann noch einen Ersatztorhüter verpflichten. Da ist das absolut sinnvoll natürlich. Aber so Barcelona ist da auch ein bisschen selbst schuld, weil sie haben es im Sommer verpasst, einen Ersatz für Suárez zu holen. Der ist jetzt auch schon 32 Jahre alt und immer mal kleine BWchen. Sie waren im Winter zu geizig bei Rodrigo Moreno vom FC Valencia. Da wollten sie die Ausstiegsklausel, ich glaube 60 Millionen, nicht ziehen oder haben versucht zu verhandeln. Und dann gab es sogar einen, wie sag ich das, peinlichen oder lustigen Zwischenfall. Da, wie heißt das, Cedric Bakambu, der spielt aktuell in China. Mit dem hatte man sich schon mehr oder weniger geeinigt oder gesagt, hier komm mal nach Barcelona, einen Vertrag kriegst du dann schon. Und dem hat man dann auf dem Weg im Flugzeug doch noch abgesagt, also es hat der Spieler dann selbst getweetet und bei Transfermarkt wurde dann als Fass zu Barcelona gewechselt eingetragen. Also es sind schon viele Dinge, wo es auch in der sportlichen Führung von Barcelona aktuell kriselt. Wir hatten vorletzte Woche so eine kleine öffentliche Auseinandersetzung zwischen Sportdirektor Abdal und Legende Messi, die da nicht so ganz einer Meinung waren. Viele Baustellen bei Barcelona, wo auch der Präsident Bartomeu mehr und mehr kriselt, auch durch die Entlastung, weil wäre das sein Freund.
Das ist wieder eine Regel, von der ich nicht wusste und bevorzuge natürlich diejenigen, die dann die Kohle haben, diese Ausstiegsklauseln auch zu ziehen. Aber so ist es eben. Es ist eine andere Liga, es sind andere Sitten. Barca jetzt mit drei Punkten hinter Real und da ist ja tatsächlich irgendwie dann doch alles noch drin, auch wenn man das vielleicht so gar nicht erwartet hätte. In der Champions League geht es übrigens gegen Napoli. Da könnte man sich schon drauf freuen. Das sollte ein Spiel werden, wo es ein bisschen knallt, um das mal so salopp zu formulieren. Dann haben wir auf Tabellenplatz 3 Getafe, die für mich relativ überraschend dahin kommen, wobei ich mich erinnere, dass mich Getafe schon häufiger überrascht hat in La Liga. Was führt denn dazu, dass die aktuell zwar sieben Punkte hinter Barca liegen, aber mit drei Punkten Vorsprung auf den Europa League-Platz aktuell auf Champions-League-Kurs sind?
Absolut, auf Champions-League-Kurs. Also das ist wirklich so aktuell die Überraschung der Saison. Kommt einerseits daher, dass ihr Trainer Jose Bordalas, der hat sich schon aus der zweiten Liga hochgeführt. In der letzten Saison hat man schon an den Champions-League-Plätzen ein bisschen gekratzt, ist dann in der Europa League gelandet, wo es jetzt im Achtelfinale gegen Ajax Amsterdam geht. Man hat einen Kader, wo nicht wirklich viel gewildert wurde im Sommer, also man hat immer noch diesen starken, wie sagt man, Dreizack vorne, das sind drei Spieler, die haben zusammen 30 Tore, das sind Marta, Ancrel und Molina, also drei Jungs, die wirklich sehr effizient sind. Getafe ist nicht wirklich für attraktiven, dominanten Fußball bekannt, also sie haben die trittwenigsten Ballbesitzwerte, die schlechtesten Passwerte in der Liga mit nur 62 Prozent ziehen, auch die meisten faulsten in der Liga, durchschnittlich 18 pro Spiel schlagen, viele die meisten langen Bälle und so weiter. Das steht nicht unbedingt für attraktives Spiel, aber sie sind vorne...
Also 75 gelbe Karten in 23 Spielen gesammelt.
Ja, sie faulen wirklich sehr gerne und sind da vorne eben auch sehr effizient. Also Marta Rodriguez habe ich jetzt schon einige Male live in, auch in der Europa, die lassen nicht viele Chancen aus und dann hat das jetzt auch am Wochenende wieder zu einem dann nicht mehr so überraschenden 3-0-Erfolg über Valencia geführt, die da wirklich teilweise an die Wand geht. Real Madrid auch, Mühe und Noten. Das war das 2-0-Sieg, glaube ich. Also die sind zu Hause in Abschluss und jetzt eben durch die Kontinuität mit dem Trainer und auch einem Kader, der nicht so viel, wo sich nicht so viel verändert hat, steht man da jetzt auch dann doch irgendwo verdient auf Rang 3. Bei Atletico kommt jetzt Diego Costa zurück und so weiter. Aber Getafe wird sich wohl in Europa halten.
Und eine der Fragen, warum da nicht so gewildert wurde, zumindest wenn es um diesen Dreizack geht, beantwortet vielleicht ein Blick aufs Alter dieser 3-Zacken diese Frage. Marta ist 31 Jahre alt, Angel ist 32 Jahre alt und Jorge Molina ist 37 Jahre alt.
Ja, das sind absolute Recken. Bei Ancre gibt es tatsächlich auch Gerüchte, dass vielleicht Barca da doch ihn irgendwie los eisen kann. Aber ich glaube, er ist zumindest noch einer, der dann doch… Der Spieler muss ja immer noch auf seinen Sein ja geben. Und ich glaube, er sieht schon noch die gute Entwicklung bei Getafe. Und da ist dann auch immer gute Stimmung im Haus. Und bei Barca kann man ja fast nur scheitern, wie so ein Boateng im letzten Jahr, der da hingekommen ist und dann kaum gespielt hat. Also ich glaube, das kann bei Getafe schon noch eine gute Saison werden. Es ist ja jetzt schon. Aber wenn es vielleicht auch eine Überraschung gegen Ajax gibt, in der Europa League, wer weiß, wie weit es da der kleine Vorort von Madrid noch bringen kann.
Also unangenehm zu bespielen sind sie definitiv. Das hast du jetzt schon herausgearbeitet. Was auch die Goldene Brücke zu Atletico baut. Die haben eine Bilanz, die ist typisch Atletico. Und ich weiß, dass ich das genauso auch schon im letzten Kurzpass gesagt habe. Das heißt, da hat sich nichts verändert. 23 Tore in 23 Spielen erzielt, 15 Tore kassiert. Das reicht dann für 10 Siege, 9 Unentschieden, nur 4 Niederlagen. Damit ist man drei Punkte hinter Getafe. Allerdings auch punktgleich mit Sevilla, die dahinter liegen. Das ließ sich so wie immer bei Atletico, aber ganz so wie immer kann es ja nicht sein. Dann wäre man Dritter.
Ganz so ist es nicht. Es sind tatsächlich auch die schwächsten Offensivwerte seit Simeone. Der ist ja der dienstälteste Trainer in La Liga, hat 2011 die Mannschaft übernommen. Also 23 gegen to'eigener Treffer, so wenig gab es noch nie. 15 Gegentore ist so eine starke Defensive wie immer. Jan Oblak ist nun mal auch irgendwie einer der drei weltbesten Torhüter da zwischen den Pfosten, der auch schon die Mannschaft einige Male gerettet hat. Vorne stottert der Motor ein bisschen, bis manchmal auch sehr viel heißt, Neuzugang, João Felix ist noch nicht wirklich angekommen, kam er vor 126 Millionen Euro. Man hat auch gut Geld eingenommen durch die Verkäufe von Grießmann, von Lucas Hernandez, von Rodrys zu City. Das waren auch 300 Millionen Euro rum. Trotzdem läuft es noch nicht so, wie das sein sollte. Dieser kleine Atleticoat, sag ich mal, dieses Simeonische Prinzip ist vielleicht hier und da immer auch mal mehr entschlüsselt, jetzt nach so langer Zeit und die Mannschaften wissen, worauf man sich einstellen muss. Real Madrid hat sie zuletzt 1-0 bezwungen im Bernabéu. Das gab es auch lange nicht mehr. Ein Liga-Heimsieg im Bernabéu über Atletico. Atletico ist immer noch die Mannschaft mit den meisten Taglings in der Liga, jeweils 17 pro Spiel. Und sie sind genauso unangenehm. Und wenn sie ein Führungstor haben, wie jetzt am Wochenende, da hat es dann zu einem 1-0-Sieg durch ein frühes Tor gegen Granada gereicht, dann verwalten sie das eben auch. Das weiß man. Manchmal kommt da noch ein Konter des Gegners dann durch oder irgendwie bricht einer durch und dann kommt sie irgendwie zu einem, man kann Granada da auch nochmal punkten. Aber jetzt am Wochenende hat es dann nicht gereicht. Also sie sind unangenehm, aber trotzdem vorne. Stodd hat es oft Morata erst 7 Tore, Costa jetzt lange verletzt gewesen. Angril Correa rettet dahin, immer mal ist noch für ein Türchen gut, aber Joraf Helic eben noch gar nicht wirklich da, noch nicht so angekommen. Und ja, es läuft einfach noch nicht so wirklich rund. Vielleicht gibt es dann gegen Liverpool in der Champions League eine Überraschung, aber die kritischen Stimmen gegenüber Simeone, sie werden lauter.
Gut, wobei gefühlt ist dieses Crescendo schon seit zwei Jahren so ein bisschen im Anmarsch. Wer weiß, wie laut die Stimmen dann noch werden können. Also dass Felix nicht gleich Grießmann ersetzen kann, das wundert einen jetzt bei der Bedeutung, die Grießmann hatte, nicht unbedingt. Welche Rolle spielen denn dann Verletzungen? Wenn ich mir die drei Mittelstürmer, die nominell für Atletico die Tore schießen könnten, angucke, dann haben wir eben Felix, der sich jetzt verletzt hat. Wir haben Morata, der schon ein paar Spieltage ausgefallen ist und vielleicht auch nicht die erste Wahl ist. Und dann haben wir mit Diego Costa, jemanden, der eben mit Bandscheiben-Vorfall jetzt länger ausgefallen ist. Spielt das auch eine entscheidende Rolle bei dem, was gerade nicht funktioniert bei Atletico?
Spielt natürlich absolut eine entscheidende Rolle. Da hat auch Atletico genauso viel Pech wie Real Madrid auch. Die kriegen es dank einem großen Kader noch irgendwie hin. Bei Atletico fehlt auch Kieran Trippier, der Rechtsverteidiger auch neu zugange, war auch so einer der besten Akteure bisher in der Saison. Also da kommt schon immer viel zusammen, hat aber dann auch immer mal was mit dem System zu tun. Zu Beginn der Saison, da waren eben Felix Morata und Costa alle fit, sprich Felix musste sich erst mal irgendwie auf der linken Außenbahn zurechtfinden. Das hat so gar nicht funktioniert, deswegen steht er jetzt auch erst nur bei vier Toren aus 24 Einsätzen wettbewerbsübergreifend, das ist noch zu wenig. Morata hat schon auch immer mal einen Lauf, aber dann auch manchmal eben nicht, gegen den Bernabéu auch ziemlich unter jetzt zuletzt beim Derby. Also ja, es ist dann vielleicht auch irgendwo doch ein bisschen die individuelle Klasse, dass es da eben nicht für die Weltklasse reicht, das was Atletico bräuchte, wenn man dann nur nur fünf Chancen pro Spiel hat, dass dann auch wirklich einer mindestens rein muss. Das kann schon ein Felix mit seinen jetzt 20 Jahren noch bringen in Zukunft, aber ist aktuell noch nicht wirklich so zu sehen, auch weil eben ja dieses immer nur reiben und kämpfen und ist vielleicht auch nicht mehr das absolute Mittel, wenn jetzt sogar irgendwie Sevilla, San Sebastian zeigen, dass man auch mit teilweise mal flüssigen, attraktiveren Fußball auch erfolgreich sein kann, auch wenn die jetzt in der Tabelle noch eins dahinterstehen.
Aber immer nur eins dahinter. Und mit Thomas Lemar, da sieht es so aus, als würde das, was so ein bisschen wie ein Missverständnis aussähe, sich auch in diese Saison weiter transportieren. An dieser Stelle würde ich dir ganz gerne die Zügel in die Hand geben, mit Blick auf Uhr und Tabelle, über welche Vereine würdest du noch ganz gerne sprechen? Alle 20 werden wir ja leider nicht schaffen.
Alle werden wir nicht schaffen. Es ist spannend, was bei den Aufsteigern passiert. Wir haben Granada, Osasuna sind aufgestiegen, genauso wie Mallorca. Mallorca ist immer noch im Tabellenkeller mit drin. Abstiegskampf. Aber Granada und Osasuna mit sehr, sehr geringem Etat haben die einiges rausgeholt. Granada war zu Saisonbeginn sogar mal Tabellenführer, ich glaube, am achten Spieltag oder so. Hat fast ein bisschen nach Lestermärchen gerochen. Aber die machen Spaß, den zuzusehen, auch wenn da jetzt auch nicht immer der absolut attraktive Fußball zu sehen ist. Dann auch mehr Konter und Kampf. Osasuna sehr heimstark. Hat jetzt zwar gegen Real Madrid die, ich glaube, dritte Heimliederlage kassiert, aber dort wildert dagegen ein Chimiavilla, ein toller Mittelstürmer, der sich jetzt leider verletzt hat. Der hätte auch einer für Barca sein können. Also da kann man immer mal reinschauen, wenn das gerade auf der Zone läuft. Valencia ist ein bisschen vogelwild die Saison. Sie haben ja den Pokal gewonnen im Finale gegen Barcelona. Aber irgendwie sind sie auch mal für einen Unentschieden gegen Real Madrid gut. Es gab jetzt diesen 2-0-Sieg über Barcelona vor ein, zwei, drei Wochen. Aber dafür verlieren sie dann auswärts bei Granada, bei Getafe, in Mallorca sogar. Also das bleibt da auch spannend, wie die sich in der Champions League gegen Atalanta anstellen. Ja klar, Real Sociedad ist sehr spannend. Sie sind jetzt ins Halbfinale eingezogen, haben die Königlichen geschlagen. Und wer spielt da? Martin Ödegard.
Ich dachte, du wirst sagen Alexander Ischak.
Ja, den gibt es auch noch. Das ist eine sehr spannende Truppe.
Lass mal kurz bei denen ein bisschen genauer draufschauen. Ich gebe zu, ich habe eingeschaltet, als ich gesehen habe, da führt jemand in Bernabéu. Das will ich mir jetzt angucken, wie die das zu Ende spielen. Und dann lief es so ein bisschen nebenher. Das sah mir tatsächlich nach sehr schönem Fußball aus, nach Kombinationsfußball. Klar, in dem Spiel haben auch wahrscheinlich Dinge funktioniert, die sonst nicht immer funktionieren werden. Aber weil da eben so viele junge Spieler spielen, mit zum Teil klanghaften Namen, wie eben Martin Oedegaard. Erklär mir mal, war das jetzt nur ein einmaliger Ausreißer oder steht das so ein bisschen stellvertretend für das, was die hinbekommen?
Das ist absolut kein Ausreißer. Also wir im Podcast von Tikitaka mit dem Alex, wir nennen Real Sociedad immer so das Hipster-Team, weil schon im Sommer abzusehen war, die haben so viele junge, interessante Spieler jetzt verpflichtet, mit dem Isak, mit dem Oedegaard. Das ist fast ein bisschen so die BVB-Rester-Rampe, weil ein Merino ist ja auch da, ein Januzaj kennt man noch. Der ist jetzt nicht so die ganz große Nummer diese Saison, aber auch ein Merino hat jetzt geknipst gegen Real Madrid. Das war schon abzusehen, dass man da viel erwarten kann von den Basken und Ödegard hat im Endeffekt nach zwei guten bis sehr guten Jahren in Holland, wo er nicht so ganz im Fokus der Öffentlichkeit stand, wo nicht jeder Fehler gleich zu einer Schlagzeile geführt hat, hat der jetzt ein Team gefunden, wo er wirklich junge, schnelle, flinke Spieler wunderbar schicken kann. Er hat ein tolles Auge, einen tollen Pre-Assist liefert der. Ist also in einer Liga mit Messi, was die Statistiken angeht in der Liga und dann eben so ein Sabal ist immer für einen Tor gut, ein Portu spielt eine tolle Saison. Merino hat jetzt mal geknipst. Isaac, was war das in den letzten 12 Partien? Ich glaube, zehnmal in diesen 12 Partien getroffen. Der hat einen Riesenlauf. William Rosset mit acht Toren eigentlich auch nicht so schlecht als Mittelstürmer. Da ist einfach die Mannschaft sehr gut aufgestellt und dank auch einem bislang überragenden Ödelgard, der so für mich ein bisschen fast der Spieler, der Hinrunde war, jetzt in der Rückrunde nicht mehr so ganz extrem aufgewiesen, da war jetzt wirklich die Partie im Benabeu, wo auch das 1-0 gegründet hat, also gegen den Club, der ihn aktuell Andreas Sosjedad verliehen hat, dann auch nicht gejubelt und fast andächtig sich entschuldigt, aber eben noch einen Traumassist geliefert, wo dann Isaac getroffen hat, wurde wegen Absatz zurückerkannt, aber das ist eine spannende Truppe, die tollen Fußball zeigt, schnelle Pässe liefert, viel über die Außen geht und dann auch vorne ein paar Knitzer stehen hat. Das kann man sich durchaus auch mal anschauen und vielleicht schaffen die es ja auch ins Pokalfinale. Im Copa del Rey Halbfinale geht es jetzt in dieser Woche. Da trifft Reals Fosjedat auf den Zweitligisten Mirandez. Mirandez hat schon drei Erstligisten ausgeschaltet, Celta, Sevilla und zuletzt Villarreal. Ist ja ein reformierter Modus, sprich keine Rückspiele mehr. Nur im Halbfinale jetzt gibt es wieder Rückspiele, deswegen haben da sich ein paar Underdogs durchsitzen können. Atletico und Valencia sind früh ausgeschieden usw. Aber es könnte die Saison von Real Sociedad werden oder auch von Atletik Bilbao. Die treffen im anderen Halbfinale auf Aufsteiger Granada, also vielleicht baskisches Derby im Endspiel am 18. April. Aber Real Sociedad auch so ein bisschen, gucke ich einfach gerne an, weil es wirklich cooler Fußball ist, schnell und Ödegard wirklich eine tolle Saison spielt, auch weil er da Keypass-mäßig in einer Liga ist mit Messi und auch viele Bälle erobert im letzten Spiel, Drittel. Es ist wirklich ordentlich.
Auch eine wahnsinnig junge Mannschaft haben den jüngsten Kader in der gesamten Liga bei nur 22 Spielern im Kader. Und wenn man die sich anguckt, könnte es sein, dass man da zumindest bei manchen die Zukunft des spanischen Fußballs sehen wird. Also wir haben ja jetzt schon ein paar Namen genannt. Eurard Sabal war einer von denjenigen, der, wenn ich mich erinnere, in irgendeinem Jugendturnier für die Spanier richtig gut aufgefallen ist, könnte sogar die Mannschaft gewesen sein, die Deutschland sehr deutlich besiegt hat. Vielleicht habe ich ihn daher noch in Erinnerung. Haben wahnsinnig viele junge Spieler mit dabei, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, jetzt in dieser Farbesaison spielt man groß auf. Man muss ja dazusagen, es sei zwischendurch sogar noch besser aus. Also aus den letzten sechs Liga-Spielen hat man ja noch drei Niederlagen eingesammelt. Da war man zwischenzeitlich schon noch weiter als jetzt nur in Anführungszeichen auf diesem Europa League-Quali-Platz, dem sechsten Platz.
Manchmal tatsächlich noch ein bisschen grün hinter den Ohren, verspielen mal eine Führung oder so. Also das kommt noch mit der Erfahrung, aber das sprichst du richtig an.
Ja, und das finde ich aber das Spannende. Also du hast ein paar erfahrene Spiele mit drin, also Nacho Montreal, kick da einfach auf hinten links, den kennen wir alle noch von Arsenal. Und dann mit Zuru Tusa noch jemanden im Mittelfeld, wobei er eigentlich, glaube ich, nicht so die große Rolle gespielt hat, wenn ich es richtig jetzt verfolgt habe. Aber dann halt diese ganzen Jungen, wo man halt wirklich sagt, ja, spannend, das könnte ein Sprungbrett für die sein. Wer weiß, wo man einen Üdiger dann noch sieht. Wer weiß, wie es jetzt mit Alexander Ishak weitergeht. Und dann eben diesen ganzen jungen Spanier, wo ich mir auch. Also wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass auch der ein oder andere da bei der Europameisterschaft auf einmal im Nationalteam auftaucht und man sich fragt, wo kommt denn der auf einmal her? Und dann ist die Antwort ja, von Real Sociedad, du hast zu wenig La Liga geguckt.
Absolut möglich. So ein Merino, ein Porto, ein Oyassabal haben wirklich eine gute Saison. Könnten da auch in Luis Henrique's erweiterten Kreis nochmal kommen. Da ist er jetzt wieder zurück im Amt, hat da jetzt noch nicht viel verlauten lassen, wen er wann, wie wo mal sehen will. Aber Martin Ödegard wird noch, der Stern wird noch weiter aufgehen. Da gibt es mit Real Madrid die Vereinbarung, dass er auf zwei Jahre verliehen wird, sprich erst 2021 im Sommer zurückkehren soll zu Real Madrid. Und dann kann er da auch wirklich das Gesicht der Neue der nächsten Jahre sein, so gemeinsam mit so jungen Spielern wie einem Fede Valverde oder auch einem Vinicius, auch einem Rodrigo. Also Ödegard, macht Spaß zuzuschauen. Wenn ihr da mal, liebe Zuhörer, beide so eine Gelegenheit habt, einfach einschalten, Ödegard gucken, macht Spaß, lohnt sich. Ich sage genauso, mal sehen, ob der noch mal zurückkehrt zum BVB oder ob der sich da in La Liga fest setzt.
Ja, man hört so ein bisschen das Funkeln in deinen Augen heraus als Realfan, kann man das gut nachvollziehen. Und für all diejenigen, die sich diese Frage genauso wie ich gestellt haben, wie alt ist eigentlich Ödegard? 21. Also immer noch wahnsinnig jung. Einfach ein spannendes Team. Gibt es noch jemanden, über den du gerne noch sprechen wollen würdest?
Es ist natürlich auch der Abstiegskampf gerade extrem spannend in der Liga. Es gibt da nicht mal einen, der sich schon weit abgesetzt hat, wo man sagen kann, die sind schon sicher weg. Da stehen wirklich die drei aktuellen Abstiegsplätze, sind mit drei Teams besetzt, die alle jeweils 18 Punkte haben. Espanol, Leganes und Aufsteiger Mallorca kämpfen da noch ums Überleben. Celta Vigo gerade aus der Abstiegszone raus. Bei Espanol ist es spannend. Die haben die schwächste Hinrunde aller Zeiten hinter sich, ich glaube auch in der Liga insgesamt. Erst einen Heimsieg, die schlechteste Defensive mit 40 Gegentoren. Sind aber dafür in der Europa League weitergekommen, treffen da auf die Wolverine Wanderers. Ein bisschen widersprüchlich.
Also sprich ein spanisches Team, ein portugiesisches Team, für alle, die die Premier League ein bisschen verfolgen.
Da ist durchaus abzusehen, dass Espanol aus Barcelona die Klasse noch halten wird, denn die haben irgendwie asiatische Beteiligung finanzmäßig, die ich diese Konstrukte nicht ganz verstehe oder durchschaue. Aber da steckt noch eine finanzielle Macht dahinter. Deswegen konnte man im Winter unter anderem einen Raúl de Tomás holen. Ex-Matrilene war jetzt ein halbes Jahr bei Benfica Lissabon, hat dort nicht wirklich funktioniert. Und jetzt ist er bei Espanol. Fünf Spiele, jedes Mal genetzt, fünf Tore insgesamt schon. Also der wird die bestimmt noch da rausholen. Und dann mal sehen, ob es dann für Eber, den 16. aktuell, noch eng wird oder so. Aber Espanol dürfte das noch schaffen. Leganes, Mallorca, da wird es wohl eher eng. Die haben dann auch eher geringere finanzielle Mittel, noch kleinere Kader. Aber Espanol dürfte noch zu rechnen sein. Und dann vielleicht auch in der Europa League mit einem Raul de Thomas wonnen.
Ja, das ist schon interessant. Also ordentlich Geld investiert. Also allein Raul de Thomas laut transfermarkt.de mit 20,5 Millionen. Da noch mit Adrian M. Barber einen Rechtsaußenspieler für 10 Millionen von Rayo Vallecano geholt. Mit Leandro Cabrera, ein Innenverteidiger aus Getafe für 9 Millionen. Also da hat man wirklich gekleckert und nein, nicht gekleckert, sondern geklotzt. So rum heißt es ja bei Espanol. Ich habe es nochmal nachgeguckt, die sind ja ein richtiges Urgestein. Also das letzte Mal in der 2. Liga haben die 1993, 94 gespielt. Das wäre tatsächlich etwas sehr beeindruckendes in negativen Sinne, wenn man da absteigen würde. Aber du hast es ja schon eingeordnet. Das sieht jetzt nicht so aus.
Das war mir jetzt auch nicht neu, aber ich war mir jetzt auch nicht so bewusst. Die haben jetzt auch schon auf der Trainerposition auch schon einiges getan. Seit Juno gab es vier verschiedene Trainer. Also Hobi wurde im Sommer abgeworben von Betis, dann kam Gallego, der wurde dann im Herbst oder so durch Pablo Macina ersetzt und jetzt eben seit Dezember glaube ich Abelardo im Einsatz, ein Expasa-Spieler, der auch so ein bisschen für mehr effizienteren, kämpferischen Fußball bekannt ist. Der es dürfte schon noch reichen, um da Espanol zu retten. Wäre schade, weil es ist auch ein absoluter Traditionsverein. Und dann hätte Barcelona wirklich nur noch einen Klub. Das ist ja in Madrid eine andere Sache mit, letztes Jahr waren es fünf Erstligisten, dann ist Rallo abgestiegen, jetzt sind es noch vier. Also Barcelona kann schon noch zwei Erstligisten vertragen.
Tatsächlich waren sie nur eine Saison in der 2. Liga. Ansonsten Seitligagrundung zumindest, so wie ich es jetzt gerade hier sehe, immer mit dabei, der HSV der spanischen Liga, um es mal so zu formulieren. Dann haben wir Leganes und...
In der Liga gibt es aber drei echte HSVs. Kennst du die?
Naja, das werden wahrscheinlich Real, Barca und... Ist es Valencia? Bilbao? Ah, verdammt, ich hab nur überlegt, einer der Basken könnte es sein. Wieder was gelernt, siehst du. Wird es denn in Spanien auch thematisiert, dass das jetzt nicht der... Also das ist ja dann kein Abstiegskampf mit gleichen Mitteln, wenn da gewisse Mannschaften so hohe finanzielle Mittel einsetzen können im Vergleich zu anderen. Wird das ähnlich kritisch gesehen wie hier, oder ist da die spanische Fußballfansäle ein bisschen anders sozialisiert?
Ist mir jetzt, was ich so hier in Madrid mitbekommen habe, nichts besonders aufgefallen, als dass es da ähnliche Widerstände gibt, wie wenn ich hier an 50 plus 1 und Kind denke, dass da Twitter-Hashtags trennen und so weiter. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht abzusehen, dass da irgendwo sich Red Bull irgendwo einkauft oder so, aber im Endeffekt, es gibt nur noch ganz wenige mitgliedergeführte Vereine. Das war Anfang der 90er noch anders, jetzt Real Madrid, Barcelona und vielleicht noch zwei, drei andere, die wirklich nur mitgliedergeführt sind, ohne irgendwie Geschäftskonstrukte dahinter. Also es ist eher schon Normalität, dass viele Vereine nicht mehr so 100% selbstständig sind, sondern wirklich auch so eine, die Geschäftsform heißt SAD. Jetzt muss ich überlegen, war das eine Aktiengesellschaft oder war das so was wie eine verkappte GmbH? Auf jeden Fall, das hat sich schon länger angebahnt in La Liga, auch wenn man da jetzt nicht direkt mit so von Investoren rechnen reden kann, wie jetzt bei Paris City und, und, und. Aber es ist entsprechend, um zu deiner Frage zurückzukommen, ist das nicht das große Thema, wenn das jetzt Espanol mehr Mittel hat als jetzt das kleine Liganes.
Okay, also es ist ein bisschen anders als hier. Und dann hätte ich noch eine abschließende Frage, auch wenn ich noch über viele mit dir sprechen wollen würde. Ich hätte gern über Roger oder Roger oder wen auch immer, den Stürmer von Levante mit dir gesprochen unter anderem. Aber dann ist mir aufgefallen mit Blick auf die Tabelle, dass es gleich drei Mannschaften gibt, die es geschafft haben, in fast der Hälfte aller Spiele unentschieden zu spielen. Valadolid 11-mal unentschieden gespielt in 23 Spielen. Atletik Bilbao 10-mal, Osasuna ebenfalls 10-mal. Kann man da irgendwas rausziehen, oder ist das jetzt einfach nur ein statistischer Zufall?
Och, Osasuna als Aufsteiger, die sind natürlich mit jedem Punkt happy, würde ich mal sagen. Und eben auch sehr heimstark, jetzt wie gesagt durch Real Madrid erst die dritte Heimiederlage hinzugefügt. Aus Osasuna glaube ich auch Barcelona noch einen Punkt abgeluchst, Bilbao war schon auch immer mit seinen überschaubaren Mitteln. Dort werden ja nur baskische Spiele aus der Region eingesetzt, auch wenn die Regel immer mal gelockert wird, wenn vielleicht mal ein Elternteil für ein paar Jahre im Bastenland gelebt hat. Aber da gibt es jetzt auch nie große Transferszugänge im Sommer, also auch da wird man mehr und mehr auf Ergebnisfußball achten, auch wenn die jetzt glaube ich seit acht Spielen ohne Sieg sind. Also das ist natürlich für die eigenen Ansprüche zu wenig. Jetzt hat man Barcelona geschlagen im Pokal, wenn auch etwas glücklich, aber da muss schon auch noch mehr gehen. Und wen hat es noch? Real Valladolid? Ja, das ist wiederum der Ronaldo-Club. Dort ist O Fenomeno, der Brasilianer, Hauptanteilseigner mit 11 Prozent. Der Ronald, nicht der dünne. Dort hat Ronaldo vor zwei Jahren oder so sich eingekauft, die Aktienminister als Präsident und Eigentümer. Dort hat man zwar langfristig den Anspruch, europäisch auch mitwirken zu können. Da wurde jetzt auch im Winter noch in Benafa, glaube ich, geholt. Also da spielen schon auch ein paar bekannte Namen, die man auch mal aus der Bundesliga kannte. Aber da ist halt noch ein bisschen Realität und Wunsch ein bisschen weit auseinander. Und dann immerhin holt man dann halt mal noch ihren Punkt, als sich direkt abschießen zu lassen.
Ja, also in der Tat, also Valladolid auf Platz 15 mit 8 Punkten Vorsprung auf die Abstiegs-Ränge. Nach oben sind es aber dann auch schon 11. Also da ist tatsächlich noch ein bisschen was zu tun, wenn man diesen internationalen Fußball da sehen möchte bei Valladolid. Und ich glaube, Ronaldo wird weinen, wenn er sich die Spiele der eigenen Mannschaft anguckt. Nach Deportivo a la Vez die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten Schüssen pro Spiel in Richtung des gegnerischen Tores. Also offensiv kein Feuerwerk, um es mal so zu sagen.
Nein, nicht wirklich. Zweit wenigstens 8,7 ist, glaube ich, der Durchschnitt pro Spiel. Das ist nicht viel. Und da war jetzt auch nach der Rückrunde, nach Rückrundenbeginn noch keine Trendwende wirklich abzusehen. Also vielleicht rutschen die da noch weiter runter. Sind jetzt auch erst seit zwei, drei Jahren wieder in der ersten Liga.
Gut, Nils, das war doch ein knackiger Rückblick auf oder ein Überblick auf das, was man bisher sehen konnte. Ich danke dir sehr. Du hast deinen Podcast ja schon genannt, den du zusammen mit Alex machst. Tikitaka kann ich sehr empfehlen. realtotal.de. Da kann man Texte von dir lesen. Auf nils.ed, nilskern17 kann man dir folgen. Nils, ich danke dir sehr, dass du mal hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst. Sehr, sehr gerne. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 145 zu La Liga. Ich hoffe, er hat euch Spaß bereitet. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützenoderauf kiosks.rasenfunk.de. Da sieht dann die Unterstützungs-Agar auch noch schön aus. Ansonsten hören wir uns wieder in einem unserer Formate. Wenn ihr wollt, würde mich freuen. Bis dahin macht's gut.